that's when you started getting tattoos  I got my first one which was Harry  Styles tattoo whatever no way right  before yeah treat people with kindness  was the first one  [ __ ] you  no tell me so much more about yourself  that's such a cool tattoo Brittany that  was really dope  you know what's on our body permanently  yeah I know that's the crazy part  is that a hairstyles quote it's like his  motto it's his motto it's like on merch  it's like I see okay you guys know about  that [ __ ] meat gang whatever yeah  it's like that this is why I'm jamming  back at it I look like the mean guy  right now for this whole time look at  your merch small man little people  what's it like down there hold on hold  your breath  you farted